opec talks front and center over the
last few weeks and again for the next
four realistically what's the percentage
that we will get a cut from OPEC on
November 30th thank you very much for
for having me as you will recall on the
twentieth of September in Algiers opik
took an all-inclusive decision to
restore stability to the market and all
our member countries agreed to the lg's
Accord to limit our production levels to
a range of 32.5 to 33 million barrels a
day for all over 14 and we remain
committed to the implementation these
are called so what is committed mean can
you give a production number for that
because the issue for the market is that
everyone wants to back out Iran Nigeria
Libya Iraq now wants to be exempt no
decision in Algiers was an all inclusive
one or 14 member countries agreed to
this Accord and in addition it was
agreed to form this high-level committee
of technical experts to work out an
acceptable framework for the
implementation of this Accord and this
high-level committee held its first
meeting this weekend in Vienna and
significant progress has been made and
we still have about a month before the
conference on November touches so we are
on course with the story in the market
over the last week was that a rock sees
itself producing more oil than OPEC
itself sees Iraq producing and they
don't want to cut our fries and they
want to actually produce more are you
saying that that's wrong no I I don't
think you have got the right information
from Baghdad I was possible in fact that
just several days ago where I met with
Jabbar away
the the the Minister of oil of the rock
together with his prime minister
al-abadi and and the President himself
and I've got a farm commitment from the
highest quarters in Baghdad that they
are committed to the implementation of
the Algiers Accords so I don't know
where you are getting your information
from so they're trying to prove those
reporters that they're actually
producing 4.7 million barrels a day
they're going on what were some are
calling a charm offensive would you be
okay if Iraq froze at that level no from
time to time our member countries to
have some differences with the secondary
sources as you know opaque has adopted
to use six different secondary sources
of data for its analysis as well as
decision-making and because of
communication difficulties sometimes
member countries do have significant
variations between their own data as
well as the data that is regularly being
churned out by these secondary sources
and like is one and they have taken the
right steps in resolving this with the
secondary sources the issue they have is
not with the paper it is with the
sources that report their data and they
have made they have assured me in
Baghdad that they are making progress
with the secondary sources in resolving
those variations and don't forget some
parts of Iraq still inaccessible because
of the difficulties they are facing so
how much are do you want Iraq to cut
production Iraq has committed itself at
the highest level of government in
Baghdad to mean that they will join
whatever consensus that the rest of OPEC
member countries will agree upon on
November touch it in order to restore
stability to the market so oh can you
give me a framework for that because how
is that really going to work are you
going to take a massive cut that you
want and divide them up between members
that
are going to be participating how's that
going to work this is a work in progress
as I told you we spent the weekend in
Vienna with our technical experts
looking at the scenarios and the latest
data including the sep tember data and
we deliberately fix the next meeting in
November 25th in order to have all the
October data in to update our database
and enrich the decision that will
eventually be taken by the conference
but you can see why markets are pretty
confused right because in the one hand
it seemed like Algiers there was going
to be a real combined cut from everybody
that's what you yourself said and then
we hear reports that Nigeria and Libya
and Iran will be exempt and then we hear
reports that there's a disagreement on
how much Iraq is willing to cut then
Russia doesn't want a cut they just want
to freeze so do you understand though
why the market then gets so skeptical of
what OPEC is doing I think it's all
misinformation because in Algiers it was
agreed by the conference that in Nigeria
and Libya and Islamic Republic of Iran
would be given some special
considerations in whatever permutations
that will come out of the framework in
the implementation of their code because
of their special circumstances so there
is nothing new in this and they are all
signatories of their code and they have
participated effectively in the
discussions we had here / over the
weekend so the issue of exemption does
not arise okay and you also spoke with
non opec producers like Russia Brazil
Mexico Kazakhstan oman how much do you
want non-opec countries to cut the
Wiccan talks here in Vienna our non-opec
friends have a very frank very open we
look at the numbers for each of the
member countries and we look at the
various scenarios but don't forget that
this committee is not a decision-making
committee it's a committee of high-level
experts
that will eventually advise the
minister's so I think it's premature for
me to state what exactly in terms of
volumes we are going to get from a lot
of it if they don't cut this out paxil
cut no they are all committed you have
had the most of these countries
including the ones that attended the
meetings here over the weekend have made
commitments to join in OPEC in taking
the appropriate supply decisions on
November touches but this is what I have
high have heard that Russia is not going
to cut maybe they'll freeze Brazil was
at the meeting but just observing
Kazakhstan is actually going to raise
output next year that's that's the
reports that we heard out of the meeting
this weekend do you say that those
reports are wrong that all three of
those countries are willing to cut
production at the end of the day we are
interested in the net supply cuts the
issue of whether to freeze all cut mere
semantics as far as weapons are at the
end of the day by the November touchid
conference we are going to look at the
net cut the net supply cuts to the
markets from each member country and
this is what we are going to inform the
market and we remain caught we remain
confident that our non-object friends
will also contribute in this regard so I
understand you're saying that's not
individual countries it's the overall
net supply but it seems hard to see
where that's coming from except for
Saudi Arabia and if Saudi Arabia is on
the hook for cutting a million barrels
of oil a day are they actually going to
do that no as I told you we are all
committed to this and come November
touch it we are optimistic that we are
going to get the required supply cut
that will go a long way in rebalance in
this market to bring the rebalancing
forth from the current projections this
market has remained too low for
too long with all the consequences on
particularly investments in the upstream
which is currently threatening future
supply so you keep talking about
commitments and you feel pretty
confident the commitments what literally
is that commitment how do you trust them
what we could be pretty mature for us
now to put the numbers on the table
because discussions are ongoing
consultations are ongoing between the
two meetings of the high-level committee
we are going to have extensive bilateral
trilateral consultations between parties
so I don't think it would be advisable
to begin to disclose numbers at the
moment but all I can tell you
confidently is that we are satisfied
with the level of commitment of our
member countries who are all committed
to the implementation of the ideas are
caught which will significantly reduce
supply to the markets impacting on the
very high level of stocks of even trees
that have been weighing down on prices
and thereby bringing the market two
buttons as quickly as we can our none of
my friends our non-opec friends
particularly Russia have also committed
themselves to join in fact they have
been playing a very important and
constructive role in this consultations
do you expect an OPEC and non-opec cut
or freeze to actually boost oil prices
or stabilize them here the the core
objective for us noun is to address the
issue of the overhang of stocks which
have risen to the highest levels in
recent times and thereby weighing down
on prices as well as keeping the market
out of balance our common objective is
to restore the stability on a
sustainable basis so
less about how far the price rallies but
more about stabilization is that what I
can understand from that yes at the
moment we have no price target but what
we what we are committed to is that we
should restore this balance in this
market and to minimize the volatility
that we have seen and to maintain this
balance on a sustainable basis and so as
to again re attract the lost investments
that we have seen especially in the E&P
as you know very well our industry is
capital intensive industry we need heavy
investments on a continual basis which
we have lost in the past 23 years for
two years we have seen severe
contraction in investments and some of
the estimates are putting this
contraction in the region of about a
trillion dollars now this is threatening
future supplies which is in the interest
of Netta producers no consumers I my
last question I just want to pivot back
to what you mentioned about Russia you
said that Russia has committed to join
OPEC Accords Rosneft the CEO there said
that Russia could actually produce four
million barrels a day more over the next
four years Russia then said that they
would not cut they would only freeze
would you be satisfied if Russia froze
their output at 11.1 million barrels a
day I have personally met with minister
legs and anova just this monday in
Vienna and he had assured me that Russia
will play its own role in the
implementation of the algae's accord and
in addition to that Russia had been also
in the forefront of mobilizing other non
opec producers to also play their part
so we are quite satisfied with the
leadership role that Russia has been
showing in this regard